etwas gutes tun während der korona krise
seit bereits einer woche wird älteren
menschen und familien die während der
korona krise in finanzielle not geraten
sind täglich ein kleines lächeln
geschenkt sie bekommen ein frisches
essen vor die tür geliefert und müssen
nichts dafür bezahlen
die aktion haben gustavus mit und
alexander sojan ins leben gerufen
wir versuchen die woche so
internationale küche präsentieren
hoffentlich alle glücklich zu machen am
sonntag haben wir extra wir gehen ostern
ein lammbraten geplant mit kartoffel
gemüse und flammenkuchen und dann haben
wir noch keine pastagericht mit
basilikum pesto schwer die tomaten und
grüne spargel wird in der aktuellen
lehrern kantine eines gymnasiums
bereiten die münchner das essen vor 35
freiwillige helfer unterstützen sie
dabei so dass täglich bis zu 1000 teller
verteilt werden können
auch der politiker florian post hilft
mit die auch soweit und sage das ohne
die vielen freiwilligen ohne die
beispiele von herrn zuhörens mit diesen
aktionen das dann dass auch solche mal
das staatliche system auch an seiner
belastbarkeit kommt die männer
finanzierten das projekt anfangs aus
eigener tasche sind jetzt aber auf
spenden angewiesen denn pro tag fallen
bis zu 1500 euro an kosten für die
lebensmittel an
wenn wir wirklich sehen dass wir mehr
anmeldungen von bedürftigen haben können
wird diese 10.000 teller auch ausweiten
das hängt natürlich auch davon ab ob wir
genügend fahrer lieben unterstützungen
und genügend spenden bekommen und auch
bate kann heute noch eine frohe
nachricht überbringen die postbank
spendet 5000 euro auf einem
tagesgeldkonto an das ehrenamtliche
corona hilfsprojekt
[Musik]